le couperet est tombé le tribunal
administratif de versailles a décidé
d'annuler l'élection municipale du chéné
rocancourt cela fait suite au recours
déposé par l'ancien maire philippe
brillault contre l'actuel premier édile
richard ii le pierre élu dès le premier
tour le 15 mars dernier avec seulement
76 voix d'avancé pour le candidat déchu
justice a été rendue est ce que les
élections du mois de mars sont sincères
c'est la question que nous avons posée
au tribunal et nous sommes satisfaites
sa réponse aujourd'hui le scrutin
n'était pas sincère et donc l'annulation
des élections
c'est ce que nous attendions du côté du
nouveau maire l'inquiétude ne se fait
pas sentir il dit prendre acte du
jugement du tribunal administratif
je pars être satisfait ou insatisfait un
moment voilà ça fait partie du droit
électoral je n'ai pas pour habitude de
commenter les décisions de justice
quelle qu'elle soit donc je resterai
fidèle à mes habitudes et donc nous ne
commenterons pas cette décision en
justice dans son jugement le tribunal a
statué que des éléments pu troubler les
électeurs en cause un sondage envoyé à
des habitants une campagne d'affichage
sauvage ou encore une publication sur
facebook contre philippe brillault les
deux parties ont désormais un mois pour
faire appel auprès du conseil d'état
on va avec mes colistiers notre avocat
prendre le temps d'examiner le jugement
est de voir la suite que nous souhaitons
donner cette décision de justice
bien évidemment va pas faire appel sur
une décision qui est plutôt notre faveur
si jamais un appel est fait cela
prolongera d'un mois la procédure avant
que le conseil d'état ne confirme ou
n'infirme la décision de justice
quoi qu'il en soit la bataille des
municipales aux généraux concours n'est
pas terminée en cas de nouvelles
élections
les deux hommes l'ont déjà annoncé ils
seront tous deux candidats